there's this idea in union psychology
called the circumambulation and Jung had
this idea that you had a potential
future self which would be in potential
everything that you could be and that it
manifests itself moment to moment in
your present life by making you
interested in things and the things that
you're interested in are the things that
would guide you along the path that
would lead you to maximal development
now it sounds of like a metaphysical
idea or a or a mystical idea even but
but it's not it's it's not it's a really
profoundly biological idea the idea is
something like well you're set up so
that you're automatically interested in
those things that we've fully expand you
as a well adapted creature well like
there's nothing radical about that idea
how else what else could possibly be the
case unless there's something
fundamentally flawed about you that is
what the the situation would be it's
kind of interesting to think about how
that would be manifest moment to moment
but the idea is something like well your
interest is captured by those things
that lead you down the path of
development
well that better be the case okay so
that's fine and so there's some utility
in pursuing those things that you're
interested in that's the call to
adventure let's say so and the call to
adventure takes you all sorts of places
now the problem with the call to
adventure is like what the hell do you
know you might be interested in things
that are kind of warped and bent and
often it's the case that when new parts
of people manifest themselves and grip
their interest say they do it very badly
and shoddily and so you stumble around
like an idiot when you try to do
something new that's where the fool is
the precursor to the Savior from the
from the symbolic perspectives because
you have to be a fool before you can be
a master and if you're not willing to be
a fool and you can't be a master so so
you're gonna it's it's an error mmm
error ridden process and that's also
laid out in the Old Testament stories
because the first thing that happens to
all these patriarchal figures when God
kicks them out of their father's house
when they're like 84 is that they they
run into all sorts of trouble and some
of its social and some of its natural
and some of it's a consequence of their
moral inadequacy so they're fools and
but but the thing that's so interesting
is that despite the fact that they're
fools they're still supposed to go on
the adventure and that they're capable
of learning enough as a consequence of
moving forward on the adventure so that
they straighten themselves out across
time and so it's something like this
this circumambulation that jung talked
about was this continual will return to
this this continual circling in some
sense of who you could be you might
notice for example that there are themes
in your life you know when you go back
across your experiences you see you kind
of have your typical experience that
sort of repeats itself and there might
be variation on it like a musical theme
but it's it's like you're circling
yourself and getting closer to yourself
as you move across time that's the
circumambulation now you remember that
for a sec because we'll go back to it
okay so imagine that something glimmers
before you it's an an interest that's
dawning and you decide well first of all
you're paralyzed you think well how do I
know if I should pursue that it's
probably a stupid idea and the proper
response to that is you're right it
probably is a stupid idea because almost
all ideas are stupid and so the
probability that as you move forward on
your adventure that you're gonna get it
right the first time is zero it's just
not gonna happen
and so then you might think well maybe
I'll just wait around until I get the
right idea and which people do right so
they're like 40 year old thirteen year
olds which is not a good idea and so
they wait around until it's Waiting for
Godot until they finally got it right
but the problem is you're too stupid to
know when you've got it right so waiting
around isn't gonna help because even if
it the perfect opportunity manifested
itself to you in your incomplete form
the probability that you would recognize
it as the perfect opportunity is zero
you might even think it's the worst
possible idea that you've ever heard of
anywhere highly likely highly likely so
so you had there's an itch of nature
called that a will will to stupidity
which I really liked so because he
thought of stupidity as being it you
know it's it's you have to take it into
account fundamentally and work with it
and so and so you can take these
tentative steps on your pathway to
destiny and you can assume that you're
gonna do it badly and that's really
useful because you don't have to beat
yourself up it's pretty easy to do it
badly but the thing is it's way better
to do it badly than not to do it at all
and that's the continual message that
echoes through these historical stories
in Genesis it's like these are flawed
people they should have got the hell out
of their house way before they did and
they go out and they stumble around in
tyranny and famine and self betrayal and
and violence and but it's a hell of a
lot better than just rotting away at
home and that's the that's great so
that's good
and so why is that well okay so you you
start your path and you think that
you're heading you know towards your
star and so you go in that direction and
then because you're here the world looks
a particular way but then when you move
here the world looks different and
you're different as a consequence of
having made that voyage and so what that
means is that now that thing that
glimmers in front of you is going to
have shifted its location because you
weren't very good at specifying it to
begin with and now that you're a little
sharper and more focused than you were
it's it's going to reveal itself with
more accuracy to you and so then you
have to take you know it's almost like
180 degree reversal but it isn't because
you know you've I mean you've gone this
far and that's a long ways to get that
far but that's a lot farther than you
would be if you just stayed where you
were waiting and so it doesn't matter
that you overshoot continually
because as you overshoot even if you
don't learn what you should have done
you're going to continually learn what
you shouldn't keep doing and if you
learn enough about what you shouldn't
keep doing then that's tantamount at
some point to learning at the same time
what you should be doing so it's okay so
it's like this
now what's cool about it though I think
is that as you progress the degree of
overshooting starts to decline right and
that we know that there's nothing
hypothetical about that as you learn a
new skill like even to play it play a
song on the piano for example you
overshoot madly he's making all sorts of
mistakes to begin with and then the
mistakes they disappear there's a great
TED talk I think it was about this guy
set up a really advanced computational
recording system in his home and
recorded every single utterance his
young child made while learning to speak
and then he put together the child's
attempts to say certain phonemes and put
them in the list and you can hear the
child deviating madly to begin with and
then after hundreds and hundreds of
repetitions just zeroing right in on the
exact phoneme so you know I
you might not know this but when kids
babble because they start babbling when
they're quite young they babble every
human phoneme including all sorts of
phonemes that adults can't say and then
they they die into their language so
that after they learn say English then
there's all sorts of phonemes they can
no longer hear or pronounce but to begin
with it's all there which is really
quite interesting but so they zip as
they learn a particular language they
zero in on the proper way to pronounce
that and their errors minimize and every
time you learn something that's how it
is and that's really useful to know too
because it means that it's okay to
wander around stupidly before you fix
your destination now you see that echoed
in Exodus right because what happens is
that the Egyptians or the Hebrews
escaped a tyranny which is kind of
whatever you do personally and
psychologically when you escape from
your previous set of stupidly held and
ignorant and stubborn axioms it's like
away from that tyranny it's like great I
freed myself from that well then what
well you think well now I'm on the way
it's no you're not now you're in the
desert where you wander around stupidly
you know and worship the wrong things
until you finally organize yourself
morally again and head in the property
action so that's worth knowing too
because you think well I got rid of a
lot of things baggage excess baggage
that I didn't need in my life and now
everything's okay it's like no it's not
you've got rid of a whole set of
scaffolds that were keeping you in place
even though they were pathological now
you have nothing and nothing actually
turns out to be better than something
pathological but you're still stuck with
the problem of nothing and that's well
that's exactly why exodus has structured
the way that it is it's that you escaped
from a tyranny it's terrain we're no
longer slaves yeah well now you're
nihilistic and lost it's not necessarily
an improvement but it is but it is the
pre let's see it's also useful to know
that because you can also be deluded
into the idea that imagine that you're
trying to become enlightened which might
mean to turn all those parts of you on
that could be turned on you think well
that's just a linear pathway uphill you
know it's just from one success to
another it's no it's not it's like here
you are and you're not doing too badly
and the first step is a complete bloody
catastrophe it's worse and then maybe
you can pull yourself together and you
hit a new plateau and then that crumbles
and shakes and bang it's worse again and
so because part of the reason that
people don't become enlightened is
because it's punctuated by intermittent
deserts essentially by intermittent
catastrophes and if you don't know that
well then you're basically screwed
because you go ahead on your movement
forward and you collapse and you think
well that didn't work I collapsed it's
like no that's par for the course it's
not indication that you failed it's just
indication that it's really hard and
that when you learn something you also
unlearn something and the thing you
unlearned is probably useful and
unlearning it actually is painful you
know let's say if you have to get out of
a bad relationship it's like not every
not any really there isn't any
relationship that's a hundred percent
bad and so when you jump out of it well
maybe you're in better shape but you're
still lonesome and disoriented you don't
know what your past was and you don't
know what your present is and you don't
know what your future is it's that's not
that's why people stay with the devil
they know instead of you know looking
for the devil they don't know so so
anyways the fact that
you're full of faults doesn't mean you
have to stop and thank God for that
that's a really useful thing and the
fact that you're full of faults doesn't
mean that you can't learn and so you can
pause it an ideal and you're gonna be
wrong about it but it doesn't matter
because what you're right about is
positing the ideal moving towards it if
the actual ideal isn't conceptualize
perfectly well first surprise surprise
cuz like what are you going to do that's
perfect
so it doesn't matter that it's imperfect
imperfect it just matters that you do it
and that you move forward so that's
really that's really positive news as
far as I'm concerned because you can
actually do that right you can do it
badly anyone can do that so that's
that's useful okay so like if you're an
efficient person you would have just
done that but you're not but who cares
you know you still end up in the in the
same place and maybe the trip is even
more interesting who knows probably two
interesting